morning everyone welcome to 609 5i
thanks for registering for this class
hope you like it
my name is stringy David us I'm a
professor of computer science at MIT
obviously and I've been teaching at MIT
for 430 years so I've been at it for a
while
the reason I'm teaching this IP class is
because I want to try out this this way
of teaching programming that starts with
the recreational world of mathematical
puzzles algorithmic puzzles and I want
to connect it up to to writing programs
and I have taught this material before
in six double oh nine that I think some
of you are registered for but but I
wanted to teach it in a in a more
interactive informal setting and I
should mention that I wrote a book on
this which is a book that's recommended
or not required for six double O nine
and so you might see this in the MIT
press bookstore and other places and
most of the material I'm gonna cover
here is from the book but I don't want
you to read the book because I want you
to listen to my explanations for the
puzzles and try and think of the the
solutions yourself and and then
obviously I do some one decoding a knot
during lecture but offline and I'll show
you some solutions to the puzzles and
there'll be some exercises so if I don't
want to spend a whole lot of time on
logistics I this is an IEP class as I
mentioned I'd like this to be informal
and relaxed so we meet every day for two
weeks we have the holiday coming up on
Monday so we'll have nine total lectures
roughly for an hour might spill over but
hopefully you'll you'll be okay with it
because you don't have you know another
class to go to at noon and if you do
yeah well let me know and I'll give you
that five minutes of
overflow personally at some at a time of
your choosing but hopefully I'll keep
keep on time so I and in terms of work I
mean this is a pass/fail it's it's a
four credit class I know some of you may
be listeners but some of you are
registered for it so I'll have to assign
you a grade so there will be some
exercises and I'm gonna make it very
simple you little that the exercise is
up on the website
there'll be do you know two days from
when I put them up and you'll have
options in terms of whether to do a
really simple exercise that's you know
probably going to take about a five
minutes or do something harder right and
for each of the puzzles there's a two or
three exercises and you get to do all of
them if you want you can choose to do
one or the other
alright I'm gonna have office hours
every day from one to two I don't plan
on putting solutions up to the exercises
the solutions to the to the puzzles
themselves they'll be shown mostly in
lecture and and put up on the seller
website but the solutions to the
exercises I'm not gonna put up but if
you ever get stuck well that's what
office hours are for and if you can't
solve the exercises I'll help you solve
them alright so did that without further
ado let's let's dive in and talk about
talk about puzzles and solving puzzles
using algorithms and then and then
programs I'd really like this to be
interactive so the police ask questions
and suggest solutions that I haven't
taught off you know that'd be great in
my second edition you know whenever that
is you'll get credit for that alright so
the first puzzle I I tried to have I
don't know funny
titles for all of these puzzles
intriguing and so the first puzzle is
called you will all confirm it this is
really a warm-up puzzle as you'll see I
mean this is true for any class things
are going to get more complicated as we
go along so if you'll probably do ten or
twelve puzzles in the next two weeks
and by the end you're going to see
things like memorization and dynamic
programming and things like that but
towards the end of next week and if you
don't know what those mean well that's
great because you're hopefully you know
you will know by the by the end of the
two weeks and a lot of these things are
algorithmic insights are insights that
will help you in course six classes for
sure and you know perhaps even if you
follow a career outside of outside of
course six all right so this particular
puzzle is as I said a fairly simple
puzzle at least to describe and the
setting is as follows so you're a
gatekeeper at a baseball game we'll just
call it a baseball game because baseball
players wear caps and you know that's
most people are watching games with caps
on and so you're a gate keeper and
there's a bunch of people standing in
line let's just say each of them knows
their number and this is Python so the
number starts at zero okay as opposed to
one and there's there's a whole bunch of
people standing in line ready to get in
and they they all have caps and some of
them you know wearing their caps for
words so with the with the I guess what
do you call it what's the front of the
cap called the shape the the thing that
gives you shape you know up front and so
we just we just say let me try and draw
this out so said this person is wearing
his cap like that and and this lady here
is is wearing her cap like this
alright so that's four words and that's
backwards okay so you're your job here
is straight forward you can only let all
of these people in into line in sorry
into the stadium that were in line if
they all
conform okay so so they all have to wear
their caps in a particular orientation
and you don't particularly care which
one all right
and so they all have to be forwards you
know all let's say you know 13 of them
are they all have to be backwards right
now all of them know their position on
the line all right so this person knows
that his position is zero this lady here
knows that her position is one etc etc
right and so so obviously you'd like to
minimize the amount of work that you do
and you could certainly choose let's say
you want everyone to be forwards you
could say hey lady in position one flip
your cap right oh I should mention
something that is important so people
have a different definition of forwards
and backwards you know that it's it's
sort of what's natural and what's
unnatural to them so so it's we think
that this person has his cap on forwards
you know before all you know he thinks
he's got his cap on backwards or
vice-versa
right so you can it assume that the
definition of forwards and backwards is
identical for all of the people in line
and and and really is the same as your
definition I mean if it seems kind of
unreasonable hey I mean this is a puzzle
ok so so so let's let's let's not argue
about that we can argue about other
things like how to write Python programs
properly so so what you have to do now
is you have to call out commands that
correspond to saying person in position
zero
flip your cap right that's all you can
say you can just say flip your cap right
and you can obviously see how these caps
are oriented and you can ask let's say
that you had something like that I'm
just making this up as I go along in
terms of I'm not going to draw all the
caps here but this is what it looks like
and so you see in according to you you
know UCF the
be in terms of forwards and backwards
and let's say you decide that you want
everyone to have their their cap on
forwards then you would you could say a
person in position one flip your cap
with person in position to flip your cap
and then person whose position for 7 etc
right and you want to make it easier on
yourself because people do know their
indices their positions in line and so
you can say to save yourself some
trouble you could say people in
positions 1 through 2 and the
implication is that it's inclusive flip
your caps right and so that takes care
of these two and perhaps you know eight
here and nine you know had their caps on
backwards and you could say are people
in positions seven through nine flip
your caps right so in this particular
example assuming that things ended with
ten people in line zero through nine you
could get away with three commands you
could say one through two and the
implication as I said this this is
inclusive flip and then you could say
four flip and then you could say is
seven through nine flip okay and if you
did it the other way you could also say
person that 0 flip and so this would go
backwards person eight three flip
obviously you can't say zero through
three because that would be wrong and
and then you could you could say five
through five through six year so you
would get three three commands in that
case as well but if in fact for
argument's sake let's just say that I'm
gonna just turn this into ten and put it
put an F down here then
these three commands would still work if
you wanted to focus on the on the bees
on the backwards people and make make
them go forwards but if you wanted to
make all of the forward people go
backwards you would need one two three
four four commands alright so so in this
particular case you're better off doing
that as opposed to doing four commands
alright so first straightforward
question is manat talking about code yet
I'm algorithmically you know just in
terms of pseudocode and I'm happy with
English how would you determine the
minimum set of commands given a
particular set of people there's an
arbitrary set of people you want to make
sure that you have the absolute minimum
set of commands and you're going to have
to use these intervals so you definitely
want to look for all the contiguous
intervals because obviously if you say
one followed and and and then that's a
separate command and you say two and
that's a separate command you end up
having more commands than necessary
right so so anyone want to tell me I I
guess roughly in in terms of pseudocode
how this would work yeah go ahead
yeah
through them and then whatever the
second one so if you have whatever the
second group is if it's ever beat those
are the ones that
from what you pass through
whatever you just tell them sounds good
do you have anything to add to that
that's good good excellent so both of
you had it right so let me explain what
these two gentleman what was your name
you're not sure what yours fatty
so Canara and fatty said so so basically
this is as I said the natural algorithm
that you would use the natural algorithm
would be that you walk through this list
and you start computing what I would
call you call it group Skinner but I'd
call them intervals right and an
interval this is something that is
unbroken
it's a contiguous it's a contiguous set
of people who all have their caps in the
same orientation you know be it forward
or backwards and what you would do in
this case is you would you would compute
the you'd say I want to look at the
forward intervals and the forward
intervals would be zero zero because
that would essentially what you have in
here and going through that list you
would get you would also say I'm gonna
be computing the backward intervals and
in this case you discover one two as the
backward backwards interval so I'm gonna
write them out like that and in general
in the mathematical notation when you
put square brackets these are closed
intervals right so so zero is included
and we're going to see a puzzle where
you might see something a little bit
different so I wanted to point that out
so one two are both inside this interval
and these two you would generate as you
would you would go through the list and
then you would generate three three over
here and then you would generate four
yep that's right just for up I'm sorry
for four over here if you want to call
it in an interval you could represent
this differently and there's nothing
that's stopping you in Python to have
these it's slightly more complicated
representation where you just have zero
here as a number and if it's just a
number then it represents an interval of
length one but let's just be uniform
about this you
usually when you have special cases and
if you do things heterogeneous Lee then
you have more code to write right it
might get more efficient but there's
usually more more code to write so you
do for four here and then you'd go up
and and then you'd have five comma six
and then you would do seven comma I'm
sorry five at seven comma nine right so
this is the first time you actually have
something interesting in the sense that
the interval has a representation that
only has two numbers in it whereas you
actually have three people in that
interval right and obviously this could
be arbitrarily large in the context of
people getting into a baseball game and
so seven through nine and then finally
here ten through ten right and so now
you go ahead and you count and you
realize that there's four intervals here
and three intervals here and then you
say I'm gonna go ahead and go with with
the backwards and asking the the people
who are well according to you backwards
to flip their caps so we're all good all
right so so I'm gonna show you code that
that implements exactly this algorithm
and while you see the code I want you to
think about this harder question on this
code is going to do exactly what we
described it's going to go compute all
of these things and it good is going to
make a pass through the entire as you
can imagine it's going to make a pass
through this entire Python list or the
set of this group of people there's a
queue of people and it's going to do
this computation then it's going to say
4 is greater than 3 and and then it's
going to go through and start calling
out commands for each of the backward
intervals so in some sense it's going to
make two passes over the the list all
right so the first pass is to get all of
the intervals together then there's a
check and then the second pass is to
take those those back those backward
intervals in this case and call out
those commands all right so that's what
I mean by two passes
yeah brilliant brilliant
you okay so so I was going to say if you
didn't understand what ganado said
wonderful because then you can you can
you can you know think about the
question I'm going to ask and ignore
what he said and and and then we'll
we'll get to the I guess the the more
efficient code but what I was going to
ask was is there a way that I'm looking
at this and I'm just going and I'm gonna
just start calling out by the moment I
see that there's an interval okay the
moment I see there's this like this is
an interval and and I'm gonna make a
call with respect to whether I'm going
to call all the command or not all right
and I'm going to do this in one pass
through this through this array okay I
want to do this in one pass through the
array I want to look at this and I say I
see the interval 0 0 all right is is
that going to be something that I need
to worry about in terms of that person
having to flip the his cap and then I
see BB and I say oh the interval is 1
comma 2 is that is that something I'm
gonna have to deal with in terms of a
command right and so someone else other
than you not wrote I tell me if there's
a there's a one pass algorithm and
explain to me of why you can do this in
one pass through the array and just in
terms of code I'll preview this the
first algorithm it needs according to my
coding which is in grade 26 lines of
code the second one needs eight lines of
code alright so yeah go ahead
how do you see the president rule there
rule you know the second interval at the
very least is gonna have the same number
of like commands as the first one so you
might as well always go at the second
one so once you've identified what type
the first interval is you iterate
through the list see like and once you
identify the person second intervals
iterate through every type of the second
interval and do a command for that Kevin
so so you had it right and and kevin has
it right as well so the observation here
is actually the if I it was said a
little bit differently by Kevin but I'm
gonna say it a little bit differently
and the observation is simply that that
if you look at the very first
orientation right the the very first
orientation is something which at best
is is going to do hat is going to be a
tie right so if you if you had it ending
at with 10 people 0 through 9 right then
the number of forward intervals is the
same as the number of backwards
intervals okay and if you went here
obviously the number of forward
intervals is greater than the number of
backwards intervals so you really only
have to look at the first person in line
to determine not to determine the
intervals because you see the first
person in line you have no idea what the
intervals are that are coming after
right I mean you can't you have to
generate those intervals so you have to
make your pass through the array but the
first person in line gives it away in
terms of what the final result is going
to be with respect to your decision as
to what set of commands you what set of
commands you're going to call up right
and so because this is an F you you you
you basically say I'm gonna go and I'm
going to make the people with the with
the bees flip their flip their caps
alright and that's that's a small
observation in in terms of I it's inside
but obviously
it's potent in the sense that it's going
to give you a one pass algorithm versus
a two pass algorithm and as I mentioned
it's going to give you a substantial
reduction in the amount of code that you
write all right
um so I'm gonna show you a bunch of code
now
right so this is usually hard this is
going to go by the way this this entire
class and this is kind of my way of
teaching at least this type of material
that's algorithmic and has data
structures and so on Internet I like
explaining to people what they're going
to see in the code without having to
deal with Python syntax and you know
worrying about whether it's while loops
or for loops and things like that and
tuples or arrays and things like that
right so let's let's get into that good
all right so the naive algorithm first
okay so what you see here is an input so
caps is is simply an input Python list
that has as you can see from our
examples the FS and the B's right and so
f is for words and B is backwards and
there's a couple of different Python
lists so you can run them with different
things and you know all of this
hopefully is not at all surprising to
you because we went through all of this
in terms of the pseudocode right so the
first initialization and I can just
highlight that to make it easy so that's
initialization and this part here the
comment sort of gives it away is you're
you're making a pass through the array
computing the computing the intervals
right and so so how do you actually get
the intervals and there's one line of
code that that does that I know by the
way there's any questions about Python
syntax you know just don't feel shy just
just tell me ask me ask me a question
and I'm happy to explain it I mean if
I'm I don't want explain things that you
all know obviously but if anyone of you
doesn't know any particular thing please
don't feel shy syntax is something that
sometimes you even forget I mean I tend
to forget things um so this thing here
is is essentially something that that
decides on when the what the intervals
are and in the insight here is simple
and you know that this interval ended
when you see something here that is
different from what the previous one is
right so that's when you know so you
generate the interval right you generate
the interval when you you go and find
something that is different from the
current location that you're pointing to
right so that's really what's going on
out here you're in in this line you say
you're setting a start here start is
your counter and remember start is
getting set again here
initially it was set to zero and if you
ever get to the point where you're
looking at I it's the next thing you're
looking at and if cap start which is the
start of the interval is different from
I it meant that the interval that began
with start ended okay
and so you essentially say well that
that needs to end at I minus one because
obviously cap start is different from
cap size so this is the end of the
interval right here all right and this
particular thing is our interval is is
is something that includes both these
two numbers so it's not exactly that but
it also includes where it might go
it also includes whether this is an F or
not so each of these things has I'm not
gonna write it out for all of those
things but I has the the orientation
inside of it so that's what you have out
here that's why we have three of these
in this tuple right this is a tuple
because it's got round brackets around
it um I could have made it I could have
made it a list if I wanted and so that's
essentially what we have here and now
here's what happens in this particular
piece of code when you get to the end
and you fall off the end so if you if
you just end then this code essentially
it skips over and doesn't it doesn't
actually put in the last interval right
because you don't see something when you
come up here and you're off the end of
the array you fall off the edge of the
array you don't see a B that is
different from F right so so this the if
you just wrote that code so something
that I'd say in many people would could
would have a would have a quote bug
where they won't add this part of the
code here because I didn't realize this
particular point that I made which and
so that last interval doesn't get added
in right and so you have a bit more code
here that decides on the last interval
and and then you count and then you go
ahead and call the commands all right so
this all looks good yeah very good with
this is there a way that I could somehow
eliminate these four lines of code which
is a little bit annoying and and just do
things in their rate how could i with a
little trick I could eliminate those
four lines of code I mean I might III
need a little bit more you know quote
pre-processing but how I eliminate that
someone else I'll get you yep
you can have an extra check wasn't it
Tanisha
so Kanishka says that before you reach
the end of the array you are or when you
reach the end of the array you go ahead
and and and and do a check that you've
reached the end and generate the
interval inside of it it just kind of
like moving this code inside of it right
so that's that's reasonable I'm not sure
that's going to be as good as the way
I'm that I want and which average which
I coded think about pre-processing think
about taking the array yeah okay all
right this how many chemins do we have
here okay so so so I you could you could
do this
right so let me let me show you
something that's a little bit more so
that was a 26 lines of code and so this
says this is the line that's interesting
so I had F and B right and so I don't
want to add F for be there but you know
what is what is convenient to do as it
turns out is to just have something that
essentially says there's an ending point
so you have an exclusive end to their a
that is actually that not something that
would crash if you try to access it
right you've added you had n people in
line and now you have effectively in n
plus 1 people in line but that n plus 1
person is a dummy right or you know you
can call them end and and then if you do
that then that's it
the previous code works right yeah you
can just remove those four lines and
you'll all just work right because your
F or your B is not equal to end right so
the the whatever you had at the end I'm
sorry I'm overloading terms here
whatever you had at the at the at the
last element whether it was a it was a B
which because it ended here or F when
you equate that to E and D you're going
to get an inequality and so that last
interval gets generated okay so it's a
small optimization Tony Hoare was a very
famous computer scientist said that
inside every program there's
smaller program waiting to get out okay
so so this is kind of one of the themes
that I'd like to to harp on in this
class which is it's nice to write
compact code usually if you can write
compact code there's fewer fewer bugs in
it and you don't want to go overboard
you don't want too many subtleties but
it's nice to ride compact code and so
this is a little bit more compact and
and then finally here's the one pass
algorithm right so the whole thing I
said the please conform one pass is the
is the the smarter algorithm that
essentially says I look if I just look
at the very first thing I'm going to I'm
gonna be able to skip that and then move
on right so this is fairly complicated I
mean it's it do I you know the algorithm
trying to map that to this code is
non-trivial so we'll spend a minute or
two on it right but here's here's how
this works
right and by the way just to make sure
so I've repeated things here so the
first the optimized algorithm for that
particular example produce these first
three commands and then the the one pass
algorithm produce exactly the same
commands right so this is good to do
it's always nice to have a couple of
different ways of solving a problem
because then you can you can verify
things right anyway so so this piece of
code is essentially something that does
the similar trick to what we had before
in terms of adding I to the to the
original list adding an element but
we're not using E and D here we're
actually saying I what what we want to
do because we're going to go ahead and
skip this anyway you know if you're
going to skip the F so we whatever that
is we could just sort of add up here
right
and it's
that's that makes it easy you don't have
to worry about what the what the actual
characters are and and cooking up this e
and D which is different from the F for
the B because you know hey it's possible
that that that people might use whatever
they want to represent a forward cap or
a backward cap so this is very clean you
go ahead and put exactly that over here
you know you're gonna skip that interval
because of the you want to skip the
first the first interval effectively
because that medalta them allows you to
do and then this part here is is doing
what we had before
we're not even generating the intervals
we're just directly making the commands
right so there's no tuples in terms of
the tuples and depending of the
intervals data structure that we had
it's all it's all gone I'm just going to
go ahead and and fire off these commands
right and those commands are are they're
written in kind of a funny way right
because I I'm going to go ahead and if I
wanted to print these things out you'd
have to do this in this funny way if
you're willing to wait and collect up
the intervals you could certainly do
that right but this is absolutely the
most compact code that I could think of
and I'm printing a command in two
different parts right I'm printing the
first part of the command that says
people in positions and that's the start
of the interval I write and I'm just
using a Python constructor this is this
E&D here is is something that the print
command can recognize and this simply
says don't give me a newline I want to
print it exactly as you saw from when I
ran the code the printing was exactly
the same as the original algorithm right
and so this e and E simply says don't
print a new line at the end of of people
and positions you know whatever this
number is call it seven and and you
don't print a new line and then you go
you have it space here because you
didn't print a new line or or a space
and you go through I minus one which is
exactly the same as we had before you
only discovered that
at the end of an interval and after you
see the person that comes after the
interval right so you have to go back to
I minus one so this makes sense any
questions about this code yeah plus
there is a concatenation and you have
two lists caps as a list and when you
use a plus operator in Python the you
you can only add things that are of the
same type okay and so caps is a is a
list and caps 0 is an element of the
list and so you need to make it a list
in order to use the plus operator you
dis also other things you could do using
a pen for example right so you could
take that line and you can do caps tour
the pen cap zero right and you wouldn't
need all of the square brackets but you
know that's just neither here or not
there but I was no obviously not
answering your question so go ahead yeah
[Music]
but but it's ok because I remember the
if statement and is is going to skip the
this one too so if I had two F's in the
beginning I think your question is what
would happen if I had two F's or three
FS in the beginning right so I'm going
to go ahead and first thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to put an F at the end
here and then maybe there's a bunch of
stuff but then the nice thing is that
I'll skip this f2 because because the
not equal to on is not going to is not
going to fire right right the next line
the caps I not equal to I minus one this
is this is going to be equal to so I'm
going to go ahead and go to the next
iteration of the loop that makes sense
did people understand fadis question
right it was a good question right so
the question was you I you skipped the
first one but what is making you skip
this one because you want to skip the
first interval correct and so that if
statement is making you do that alright
good so as you can see even a fairly
straightforward puzzle this is
the simplest puzzle we're going to do
here right is the first one you know and
there's nuances associated with how you
solve it but also how you code it right
and this is kind of I said you know my
this was my Eureka moment you know a few
years ago but I said I think the way you
want to teach programming is is is at
least some some aspects of programming
is in this fashion right anyway good so
we're done with this any questions about
this puzzle all right
you